that moment for me was really really
really hard I'm thankful to life in one
way is that it could have been his
passing away could have been way more
dramatic than that in the situation he
was in
Celine Dion is opening up about her
tragic year to Katie Couric in a new
interview with Yahoo News Rene Angelil
passed away in January and Celine
credits an animated movie with helping
her explain his death to their
five-year-old twin boys I talked to them
about the movie pop-up was from it saved
my life I said what is the movie that
Lily died and they said he died in the
movie odd mom I said that's it Edie I
said well I want you to know listen to
me
I said petha is not within him Celine
also credits her kids and fans for
supporting her through her loss
something she also told ET in July
they've been always it was always there
and when Rene passed
I was extremely touched by the fact that
they was so so they're passing away as
part of life and many things help you to
go through this yes music yes fans
yes family entourage but especially my
kids